how much of you being a screenwriter is
about the love of writing versus the
love of writing so that a movie can be
made from it I mean is it something that
is painstaking for you to sit and and
ten hours may go by and you won't think
of a line of dialogue or is something
that you love the process as hard as it
is or you love it because it produces a
movie that's interesting
both you know I love the writing process
I really do and I love being able to
paint pictures with words I love writing
a story I love being able to tell a
story over three acts or two acts and
you know you could write a two octave
film and you can write these great
characters so you I love writing writing
is like such a passion for me but it's
also because you know if you want to say
something there's not a better person to
say than yourself so as a director
sometimes you just you're forced to
write your own words because you want to
get your vision on screen so it's it's
never really come down to me trying to
create a product that's not what
screenwriting is for me to create a
product to go make a movie so that's not
really my intention as a screenwriter
but it's always about me telling the
story I want to tell and i've co-written
stuff with buddies and friends and other
great writers but i I really like at
times just you know being able to say
what you want to say as a director but
you want to put on screen but doesn't
mean I don't want to direct other
people's words because I think that's
just as valuable but as a necessity as a
writer director it's because you have a
vision that you want to write that's in
your mind someplace that's in the back
of your head and you can tap like these
beautiful places and tell these
beautiful characters or scary characters
and it's easy to translate it from your
brain to your fingers to the screen okay
that's interesting so it's it's about
getting out what you want to say not
having this thing where look this is a
movie and as screening in this festival
it's it's this burning desire to
like make a statement about something
yeah yeah have you always been like that
even as a kid I have you sure asked my
parents are probably so yes I've always
been the one that wants to scream really
loud so we you know certain kids are
more sort of precocious and they have a
statement they want to you know proclaim
to the world and then others were the
sort of the quiet one so I just wasn't
sure that I was the first one oh yeah I
was hands down the first one
you